gibt apple heute versammelt dukan
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
mini unterrichten wir haben hier jeder
fertig
[Musik]
wir haben jeder wenn ich dann startet
luca und einmal wagte und wir bekommen
jetzt fragen gestellt von jana neben dem
mikro unterfranken beispielsweise wäre
würde er nicht nominierte den fuß kleben
dann zeigen die beispiele sind schild
hoch und dürfte so was dort steht das
ganze video also die liebe der fans
wirken
[Musik]
müller nähe war 3 zwei weitere täter
das bist du ja ich bin aber eher dafür
wie beiden ich war an nicht überlegt ob
ich schon mal gemacht habe
ja ich will auch so was wieder die
einfach im karton liegen und legte
karton wurde ecke auch schon mögen
bleibe ich mal sein würde sich wenn man
die pizza in den müll einfach mal werde
er wie ein video drehen
ok keiner so ja keiner
viele konzerne hätten nicht mit der für
eine komplett andere videochat über eine
chance die man andere chance gute chance
wahrnehmen wir müssen hier beim
einschreiben gegenüber
das werde sich eher die haare komplett
abrasieren
ich wollte aber was gehört lockt auch
ich war in wahrheit kurz davor aber ich
habe dann wäre gedanken der dauert soll
dann wird wieder lange warten will dem
defensiven kopf und betrieb kompletter
sehen wenn ich mit der außenwelt zu
wissen welcher auch viele haare habe ich
jetzt ein bild aldi markt ohnehin würde
das wird keiner von uns machen irgendwie
doch ich glaube ich glaube weil du
überhaupt auch immer wenn du was gegen
die weltbeste skihütte wisse wann band
the chariot die du halt verloren haben
wir mehrere heime wechseln lieber dieser
röckchen schnarcht durch die innenstadt
gelaufen bis ihm die controller einfach
um den grundschulen oper almira gemacht
einfach oder handy ein paar reisen ja
wer richtig auf wo da willst du ein
experiment gewagt man wolle ja ich
glaube mir auf mich selbst weil keiner
fakt nicht wie immer was anhängig zu tun
zu haben ich glaube würde relativ gästen
ohne ankündigung direkt machen würde
dann wird spätestens nach zwei tagen
wird meine eltern ihr vor der tür stehen
und würden wir sagen hey lebst du noch
nie verlegen weil man hat ja gar keine
kommunikation mehr ertragen doch mal ein
laptop darf dann nur dann würde ich
vielleicht weitermachen mit holen
ich würde das nicht hinkriegen bei der
eltern da als etwa die beide mit affären
werde er einen verzicht auf die barocke
[Musik]
eine ewigkeit später nicht vorstellen
können
ja ich weiss nicht einfach nur auf die
wange küssen kompetenten menschen karten
komplett fälschen
so also genommen einfach ein mensch hat
ja edelmann normal und familie die damit
bei auf die wage keine radio und
mittlere ich weiß nicht also den
kompletten werden liebe hin statt ein
paar und diese bereiten sich auf die
berge kirchencafé hardware business
video macht wurde einfach mensch auf der
straße gekürzt hat irgendwelche konten
und kann den vertrag schild oder kannst
du unendlich viel essen ich mich wohl
aber auch viele essen so arbeitet kann
dieses video widmet ihr übergeben
ich bin viel verändert ja wer für die er
wirklich retten darf entwickle jedoch
doch weil nur afrika ägypten oder aber
eine frau stand wenige üblicher
verpasste aber er glaube als wir
irgendwann mal in die schule pizza
bestellt haben und ich habe direkt auf
gehen obwohl ich weiß nicht ich glaube
dass meine pizza schlecht war ich zu
viel gefressen aber ich habe auch viel
gewesen
per flugzeug einsteigen ohne geflügel
war mit leuten zum flughafen gefahren
häufig bewegten fluten arbeiten bin ich
im flugzeug gestiegen weil ich hätte
halt ehren gedacht also zumindest preise
angeht mag ich eigentlich das verbot zu
klaren für das ipad anbieten dass das
hotel dann klaus hat sich drückt weil
ich dachte das durchhalten werden wir
auch verbraucherschützer halt irgendwann
machen wollte da ja auch egal ob ja eine
klare klatsche ein bisschen ja genau
irgendwie warum ich sage wenn du mich
immer zum flughafen gefahren wissen
einfach den nächsten problem wollte
zweimal capitals liegen jetzt noch ein
paar jahre später okay doch wir hatten
einmal gedacht dass wir abend mit den
jungs oder uni wir wollten am ende
gedachte knapp hinter der uni waffen
beten oder fliegen würden über nacht da
bei einer david morgan rücken würde
alles in kriegen finden und flughafen
gefahren aber die meisten hat mich vom
flughafen dem angebot für feuerwehr den
geld nicht mehr weil wir die wege frei
unter dem irgendwie verändert wurde
anhand einmal haben wir halt einfach
wieder geiler tag auf das irgendwie auf
malle oder so aber dabei flughafen aber
nicht dass diese zeiten nicht einfach
irgendwo hin und wieder geschlafen habe
am nächsten tag weiter ein kauf mit
meinem bruder wir haben es auch kurz
abgestellt
er würde das auto erhalten da wurde
erhält da haben wir
er einen weiten ball auf jeden fall
geben die ein kopftuch getragen sollten
um park mit direkter allerersten park
und daraufhin schlüsseldienst bedanken
aber wenig dafür oder euro war das mein
weg von dort hatte er ist ein boxer
durch den macd drei wochen als video
idee aber das gab das ich nicht aber
auch stücke werden mit könnt ihr das
machen unsere videos mit dem einkauf
bieten alle er würde er einfach mit
frauenklamotten zum laufen
kimball ein bild einen ganzen tag lang
machen mich würd's mit you ich habe mir
ich hab mir besser meine video
geschminkt daran habe ich gerade so
gedacht wenn du das mit ihr machen lässt
dann läufe konnten aber änderungen wäre
ohne grund wird pepe aber irgendwie so
ein video das was gemacht wird dann wird
mit würfel video ist also machen du
musst also ein vorstellungsgespräch und
aus dem ersten weltkrieg man erst fertig
los geht noch einiges klar
du bist nicht wieder werden beim
vorstellungsgespräch katja wer würde er
mit marc friedhöfen erwartungen
[Musik]
gastspiel findet andere ich mit dem
gedanken ich hab' ich habe werde ich mir
hätte dazu verpflichtet gesagt später
führt der referent für live-wetten
monaten sagen und das urteil der gedanke
ich davon abgeraten hat also ich war
drauf und dran eben lieber etwa in
bocket oder so irgendwie irre was klein
alt oder am pool oder kannst du da
gemacht wird
hier sind wir trainer müssen wir
irgendwo ich wollte dass auf jeden fall
machen aber dann habe ich herrn gehörte
sind nicht fähig ist weg geht und ich
hasse es wenn du was will ich denn
bestimmt also wenn man irgendwas zehn
jahren verändert sich das komplette
ausfall eines menschen hat allerdings
das finde ich nicht so cool wieder meine
damen und herren mag formal mag kommt
ein video
wir haben wir haben wir haben das
gleiche auch für die haben ja das
gleiche aufbewahrt kanal auf gestorben
ist war doch nicht aber machen wir
gleich jeden fall bittet video macht
irgendwann in der nächsten paar jahre
kommt er wirklich auf heute kommen
internet liegt wien ich gehe oder auf
baum kommt also checkt kanada wird
irgendwann hochgeladen wer das video
gefallen getan hat was gerne leichter
ihr findet jetzt hier eine weil die
eingebettete darauf liegt bei kanal
abonnieren hier findet gegen andere
video eingeblendet
[Musik]